[Musica]
una sera non riuscivo a dormire e come
sempre dopo un po' mi è venuta fame
rigorosamente troppo pigra per alzarmi
però sono rimasta nel letto a pensare a
rimus inare e ho pensato a quante volte
nella vita Abbiamo fame ma ci fa fatica
alzarci a cucinare
oppure ci accontentiamo di qualcosa che
abbiamo in frigo anche se non ci va
perché l'abbiamo comprato una settimana
fa al supermercato era in offerta e lì
per lì sembrava un'ottima idea Ecco io
credo che a volte
ehm l'amore somigli un po' al
cibo quante volte nella vita apriamo
apriamo il frigo più volte a distanza di
30 secondi sperando che questa volta si
sia materializzata quella cosa di cui
abbiamo tanta voglia e e che magari
prima c'era sfuggita perché non avevamo
guardato
oppure proviamo a replicare piatti che
ad altri sembrano venire bene senza
sforzo mentre noi ci ritroviamo con la
cucina imbrattata e un impasto troppo
liquido di cui non sappiamo cosa
farci se dovessi partire dalla mia
ultima relazione sarebbe una relazione
kebab Stai tornando a casa hai fatto
serata E magari sei in chimica magari
Hai ballato tutta la notte Insomma hai
fame cammini e a un certo punto appare
lui un bab Ora sai lo sai che non è il
più buono in zona e che ce ne sono altri
di migliori Sì però non sai se gli altri
saranno aperti E poi vedi l'offerta
kebab €4 e tu hai soltanto €4 e
quindi entri un po' per la fame un po'
per paura di perdere l'occasione e un
po' perché appunto hai solo
€4 compri questo kebab e lo mangi ed è
la cosa più buona che tu possa mangiare
è quello di cui hai bisogno in quel
momento
così torni a casa con la pancia piena Ti
metti sotto le coperte il giorno dopo
avrei sicuramente un engover più leggero
Ecco sono quelle relazioni che iniziano
un po' per caso
e non non sono perfette però servono a
superare un periodo che può essere anche
più o meno lungo però è momento Perché
per quanto buono non si può vivere di
kebab le prossime
relazioni sono relazioni sushi se sul
letto hai fame ma non sai di cosa scorri
Instagram annoiato Quando all'improvviso
lei la foto del Sushi Ecco hai voglia di
sushi lo sapevi Lo sapevi hai voglia di
sushi e improvvisamente diventa una
voglia irrefrenabile tu devi andare al
sushi Quindi prendi ordini chiami e ci
sei Apri Il menù lo sfogli e ordini
tutto tutto compreso di sedie tavole e
cameriere e e poi aspetti impaziente che
arrivino gli ordini Endo le bacchette
nella salsa di soia e poi finalmente
arrivano i primi piatti e sono
buonissimi E ti chiedi Ma perché non
perché non vengo più spesso al sushi con
il riso che si impregna della salsa di
soia la tartare di salmone che ti si
scioglie in bocca e bevi la zuppa di
miso cercando di compensare l'acqua che
che non vuoi aprire tutto è meraviglioso
mangi mangi
mangi Ma gli ordini continuano ad
arrivare a un certo punto inizi a
masticare a fatica respiri e hai il
terrore che il cameriere stia venendo di
nuovo verso il tuo tavolo per portare
altra roba hai ordinato
troppo quindi inizi a schiacciare le
palle di riso tra i piatti da portare
via le disintegri nella salsa di soia e
quello che avanza lo metti in un
tovagliolo te lo infili in borsa e
scappi via mai più una cosa del genere
mai più Ecco sono quelle relazioni che
sarebbero anche una buona idea se solo
tu riuscissi a non ordinare subito tutto
il
menù e poi c'è da dire che dopo una
settimana guardi di nuovo Instagram vedi
la foto del sushi e hai di nuovo voglia
di sushi
opposte sono le relazioni
pasta la pasta la mangiamo un po' tutti
i giorni e e forse si dà un po' per
scontata però poi quando vai via di casa
all'estero Ti rendi conto che la cosa
che ti manca di più è proprio un piatto
di pasta e poi si può fare in mille modi
diversi con sughi molto elaborati oppure
già pronti e anche quando è in bianco è
molto buona Ecco sono Sono quelle
relazioni che si capisce non sono un
dolce al cioccolato una bistecca al Sang
o una pizza è
pasta quindi forse sì somigliano più a
una profonda amicizia però se dovessi
scegliere un piatto da mangiare per
tutta la vita sarebbe sicuramente la
pasta ecco nella vita ci sono anche le
relazioni fast food ci vai una volta
così perché ti va ti piace e inizi ad
andarci
spesso inizia ad andarci un po' troppo i
tuoi amici ti dicono Ehi rallenta Non è
che ti fa bene e tu tu ti arrabbi perché
dici voi voi non capite Io sto facendo
un ottimo affare pago poco e mangio bene
poi sì sai la storia di quel tipo che è
andato un mese di seguito in quel fast
food e ciè quasi rimasto però un po' non
ti interessa e un po' non ci credi
perché magari aveva qualche patologia
pregressa magari aveva una particolare
predisposizione insomma a te non
capiterà e poi il problema delle
relazioni fast food è che non si vedono
subito gli effetti collaterali a volte
ci mettono anni anzi anche quando
verranno fuori non è detto che tu voglia
vederli sono relazioni tossiche Dalle
quali è difficile uscire e a volte ci si
riesce i primi segnali a volte Appunto
ci si resta intrappolati per anni
l'importante però è uscirne E poi è
difficile perché la città è disseminata
di fast food e la tentazione di fermarsi
ogni volta giuro solo per delle patatine
è forte perché poi entrerai e e troverai
il menù doppio in
offerta simili ma meno letali sono le
relazioni da piatto
stellato una volta prendi e ti chiedi ma
chissà come sarebbe mangiare in un
ristorante stellato hai un po' di soldi
da il vestito pronto per l'occasione
quindi chiami ti metti l'anima in pace
aspetti e prima o poi però trovi posto
entri al ristorante e ti senti subito a
disagio perché è evidente che è un
target troppo alto per te però ormai ci
sei e non ti resta che bleff quindi
Prendi la carta dei vini ordini un vino
a caso facendo finta di sapere cosa stai
facendo e poi prendi il menù sgranando
gli occhi ogni volta che con lo sguardo
passi dal nome del piatto al prezzo però
ci sei ordini arrivano i piatti insieme
all una spiegazione di cui non capisci
niente e sono molto belli effettivamente
quindi tiri fuori il telefono Fai una
foto e la metti su Instagram ed è questo
il vero motivo per cui sei qua
improvvisamente si apre un rubinetto di
mi piace i Direct pieni di gente che è
contenta per te e che vorrebbe essere al
tuo posto e quindi mangi contento Però
le porzioni sono piccole e costano tanto
quindi va a finire che esci un po'
frustrato e e un po' affamato Ecco sono
quelle relazioni che forse abbiamo
perché piacciono più agli altri che a
noi stessi oppure sono quelle persone
con cui cioè quella persona con cui
abbiamo sempre desiderato stare ma che
quando poi
succede Non è come ci aspettavamo e poi
richiedono tanto sforzo servono tante
energie tanti soldi e un BFF continuo
Insomma sono belle sono belle sono
piatti buon buoni Ok Però ne vale la
pena infine quando si cresce un po' e
passa il il fascino per il lusso la
voglia di Sapore di fritto economico in
bocca si imparano ad apprezzare anche le
relazioni
verdura soprattutto quando è più P se è
più piccoli è difficile perché la
verdura non è il piatto preferito di
nessuno e anzi se si può si evita però
ecco quando poi si scopre la cucina
vegetariana ci rendiamo conto che ha dei
sapori che pensavamo potesse avere che
sono
complessi e buoni e soprattutto quando
si mangia sai che stai facendo bene a te
e all'ambiente sai che stai facendo
qualcosa di positivo poi sì anche queste
sono relazioni impegnative
perché insomma nella cucina vegetariana
i piatti sono più cari il cibo biologico
è più caro serve un po' di inventiva in
più tempi di preparazione più lunga
Insomma bisogna volerle Ecco sono quelle
relazioni che sono più complicate ma
perché bisogna mettere in conto di
crescere dove L'obiettivo non è più
quello di cambiarsi a vicenda ma di
migliorarsi quelle relazioni in cui per
stare al passo con l'altra persona
bisogna
correre è così sono faticose Però ne
vale la pena
Grazie in realtà in realtà ce n'è
un'ultima che che è la mia preferita e
sono le ricette di tiktok Insomma hai
appena mangiato magari oppure sei per
andare a letto Insomma non hai Non è che
hai fame però apri tiktok e ti metti a
guardare e finisci in questo miliardi di
ricette diverse dici cavolo buona questa
prima o poi la facio e metti mi piace la
verità è che non te la farai mai Però
metti che una volta ho voglia di provare
a cucinare la carbonara di pesce vegana
con scaglie di Grillo cotto in sale
dell'himalaia Insomma metti che una
volta ho voglia di farlo e che fai Non
te la salvi
grazie